[Gelächter]
am Wochenende erreichten uns ungewohnte
Bilder aus China wütende Menschen
demonstrieren gegen die strikte
nullcovit-politik jetzt greift die
Regierung hat durch setzt auf Gewalt und
totale Kontrolle China ist unser
wichtigster Handelspartner aber die
Diskussion ob das so bleiben soll die
ist eröffnet das Wirtschaftsministerium
will eine größere Unabhängigkeit
deutscher Firmen auch weil man mit einer
annexionsteilvans rechnet Proteste in
China wie umgehen mit Peking unser Thema
in der Phönix Runde
schönen guten Abend herzlich willkommen
aus Berlin und das sind meine Gäste bei
uns ist haugui er ist Redakteur der
asienprogramme der Deutschen Welle er
ist geboren in Nanjing in China und lebt
seit 1999 in Deutschland ich begrüße
Jensen stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
FDP-Bundestagsfraktion und Mitglied der
deutsch-chinesischen
Parlamentariergruppe und vor einem Monat
waren sie noch zu Besuch in Taiwan und
herzlich willkommen Professor Stephan
KOZ Vizepräsident des Instituts für
Weltwirtschaft in Kiel und dort Direktor
des Forschungszentrums Konjunktur und
Wachstum und zugeschaltet in Peking ist
uns Miriam Steiner sie leitet dort das
ZDF-Studio schönen guten Abend Frau
Steiner begrüße sie und würden gerne mit
ihnen beginnen wir haben am Wochenende
diese vielen Proteste gesehen wie sieht
es im Moment aus auf chinastraße
ja Moment ist es auf Chinas Straßen eher
ruhig das liegt vor allem an der
massiven Polizeipräsenz also wir waren
gerade gestern noch mal an dem Ort wo
wir am Sonntag auch bei der
Demonstration hier in Peking dabei waren
da ist davon nichts mehr zu sehen also
auf einem Mauervorsprung gibt es noch
ein bisschen Kerzenwachs aber das war's
aber was dort ganz klar zu sehen ist ist
ganz viel Polizei also mehrere
Polizeiautos in der Straße und von einem
auch sehr viele Aufpasser in Zivil und
so sieht es auch vielen Straßen in China
gerade aus es ist glaube ich auch ein
Grund warum er keine größeren Proteste
mehr sehen also natürlich gibt es immer
mal wieder Videos von kleineren
Zusammenstößen das sind dann aber
Einzelpersonen oder kleine Gruppen aber
nicht mehr die Massen wie wir sie am am
Wochenende in vielen Städten in China
erlebt haben ist das weil die Menschen
zu viel riskieren oder was kann
passieren wenn sie weiter demonstrieren
würden oder ist es einfach hier
unmöglich wir noch auf die Straße zu
gehen
ja ich glaube es ist beides also man
muss sich noch mal eine Erinnerung rufen
jeder der am Wochenende auf der Straße
dabei war muss mit Konsequenzen rechnen
wir haben ja gesehen es gab schon
Verhaftungen wir hören von vielen die
dabei waren die jetzt Anrufe von der
Polizei bekommen oder auch Besuche von
der Staatssicherheit also da läuft
gerade die Maschine auch auf Hochtouren
und da hilft natürlich die digitalen
Überwachungsmöglichkeiten die China
sowieso schon hat also jeder der dabei
war auch mit Maske auch mit Kapuze ist
aufgezeichnet worden und kann gefunden
werden es gibt außerdem aus mehreren
Städten die Berichte dass Polizei die
Handys von Passanten kontrolliert also
die schauen sind da Videos oder Fotos
von den Protesten drauf sie löschen
solches Material sie schauen auch sind
westliche Messenger Apps installiert mit
den haben sich die Demonstranten ja vor
allem ähm
verabredet zu diesen Demonstrationen
also es wird zum Beispiel nach vpn-apps
geschaut also VPN ist sozusagen die die
App mit der man dann neues Internet
empfangen kann natürlich auch verboten
also diese Kontrollen das alles dient
natürlich auch der Einschüchterung der
Proteste sie bleiben die ganze Sendung
bei uns zugeschaltet also wir reden dann
darüber noch weiter Herr GUI sie haben
auch noch Familien in China waren vor
Corona vor drei Jahren das letzte Mal im
Land denn danach ging es dann einfach
gar nicht mehr wie nehmen sie denn die
Proteste jetzt Wahl wie haben sie damit
gerechnet
ja nicht ganz ehrlich bin habe ich damit
nicht gerechnet so viele Menschen auf
einmal auf die Straße gingen und zwar
sie haben nicht nur gegen die nur kovic
Politik demonstriert sondern auch
politische Forderungen gestellt das ist
ähm hat mich wirklich sehr überrascht
das ist
gerufen haben runter oder
beziehungsweise dass die dass die
Regierung zurücktreten soll das der
Staatspräsidentin dafür verantwortlich
gemacht werden soll für einzeln hört man
diese diese
Forderungen
muss man sich verborgen vor diesen
mutigen Menschen die wirklich alles
getan wir haben alles riskiert haben um
einfach die politische Forderung zu
stellen
die Lage heutzutage so wie ich das
richtig höre auch aus dem Kreis meine
Familie ist dass die Lage sehr ruhig ist
das ist zum Teil auch darauf
zurückzuführen das Polizeipräsenz
verstärkt ist auf der anderen haben die
Menschen glaube ich die ersten
Erfolge aus ihrer Sicht erzielt das das
dass sie gehört wurden von der
internationalen Gemeinschaft und dass
die Gerät ausgerechnet Peking wo die auf
Straße ginge ist ja wo ein fitte wo sehr
viele Diplomaten sind wo die Botschaften
sind und das so erstmal eine
internationale Aufmerksamkeit darauf
gerichtet sie sind das lebt heute leider
ausgegebenen anders ein bisschen in den
Schatten weil heute die Staatstrauer
beginnt bei der ehemaliger
staatspräsidentinär gestorben ist also
die ganze Familie gestorben ist und die
Staatsfrau wurde angeordnet ist die
Stadt Propaganda einseitig nur über den
Tod bzw sehr über die draufweihe
berichtet und das dass diese
corona-demonstrationen leider ein
bisschen Vergessenheit geraten ist aber
das kann ja auch sein dass sie wieder
aufflammen obwohl es so schwierig ist
also wo man ja eine Menge riskiert Frau
Jansen war ja wirklich eher kam es
überraschend weil man hat ja dann erst
vorher im Oktober noch eben diese
eindrucksvollen machtbilder gesehen vom
Parteitag und von diesen Ping der sich
dann hat wieder wählen lassen oder
wieder gewählt wurde wie bewerten sie
das aus politischer Sicht was dort
passiert jetzt also ich war auch
überrascht über die Bilder weil wir ja
durchaus wenig aus aus China auch dieser
Videos von Demonstrationen sehen das ist
ja nichts ähm was dort häufig kalt hat
und ich glaube die Tatsache dass wir am
Wochenende noch mehr bei Twitter
verfolgen konnten und das jetzt schon
wieder weniger wird es liegt einerseits
es hat die Kollegin in Virginia richtig
beschrieben ist die zensurmauer wird
wieder hochgefahren aber ich glaube das
was wir jetzt politisch sie fragten nach
der Bewertung das was der erste
Bewertung immer ist wir müssen versuchen
Verstärker zu sein für die Menschen in
in China die protestieren weil die nur
bedingte Möglichkeiten haben und ich
frage mich dann immer wie groß der Druck
eigentlich in diesem Land sein muss dass
man trotz dieser Repressionen und das
wurde ja gerade eindrucksvoll noch mal
geschildert trotz Verfolgung Anrufe zu
Hause auch ja möglicherweise
Konsequenzen man verliert vielleicht
seinen Job man bekommt keinen keinen
kein keine Wohnung mehr das zahlt ja
alles negativ ein auf dieses social
creativ-system
trotz allem auf die Straße geht und für
Freiheit oder für für Veränderungen
demonstriert also da waren ja Hufe laut
wie nieder mit dem Ping da ging es nicht
mehr nur um Corona das war sicherlich
der Anlass aber vielleicht können wir
erklären dass nur credit System das ist
ja jeder sammelt ja Punkte sozusagen ja
im Grunde wird gesellschaftliches
Verhalten dass das System
befürwortet positiv bewertet wenn man
sich entsprechend des Systems verhält an
Regeln hält und sobald man das nicht tut
gibt es Punktabzug sag ich es ganz ganz
platt aber das Verhalten wird bestimmt
durch die Kommunistische Partei was
vorgesehen ist das geht so weit machen
nur ein Beispiel weil es so so irre ist
eigentlich wenn jemand zu häufig den
Hintereingang seines Hauses benutzt gibt
es Punktabzug wenn jemand zu häufig den
Vordereingang benutzt gibt es auch
Punktabzug also es ist wir haben darüber
mal in einer Ausschuss Anhörung im
Menschenrechtsausschuss gesprochen also
die die Art wie das System versucht die
gesamte Bevölkerung zu gängeln wird im
Grunde in diesem System sehr deutlich
und
da ist kaum Raum für für freiheitliche
Luft und dennoch protestieren
weil man merkt das Land leidet vor allen
Dingen auch unter der Null Kuh wird
Politik deshalb die Frage an Sie her
kurz wie geht es dem Land eigentlich
wirtschaftlich also was hat Corona mit
Strategie mit dem Land gemacht ja die
Ökonomie die tatsächlich gewachsen sind
und eben nicht die
unproduktiven großen Staatsbetriebe und
seit zehn Jahren versucht man eben auch
nicht nur eben im politischen Bereich
sondern eben auch im ökonomischen
Bereich immer stärker
interventionistisch einzugreifen stärker
zu lenken und das droht eben diesen
Produktivitätsschub zu dämpfen und
deshalb muss man sich von dieser Seite
her eben nicht nur muss man sich eher
Sorgen um China machen als vor China
also was dem Land eben wirtschaftlich
schlechter geht als man es erwartet
hatte auf jeden Fall unter seinen
ökonomischen Möglichkeiten ist altert ja
sehr stark wir sind vermutlich in diesem
vielleicht im nächsten Jahr so auf dem
Scheitelpunkt der
Bevölkerungsentwicklung die Bevölkerung
und dann geht es dramatisch abwärts und
die Sorge ist ja dass sich China
schneller altert als es reich wird und
deshalb brauchen sie eigentlich jeden
wachstumspunkt und jetzt seid verspielen
sie einfach zu viel ja Frau Steiner ist
das ein Punkt wo den man den sie auch
merken dass es eben die dass das
wirtschaftliche Wachstum oder die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung nicht mehr
so positiv ist ist das auch ein Teil der
Wut die sich da entlädt oder spielt das
keine Rolle
doch das ist definitiv so also gerade
also nach jetzt fast drei Jahren
Pandemie die muss vielleicht noch mal
klar machen die Menschen die im Lockdown
sitzen können ganz häufig nicht arbeiten
also und dann heißt es auch sie sind in
ihrer Wohnung eingesperrt und können
kein Geld verdienen wir haben mit
mehreren Menschen schon Interviews
gemacht die halt sagen ich habe keinen
Einkommen mehr aber alle meine Kosten
laufen natürlich weiter es gibt dann
staatliche Unterstützung die
funktioniert mal besser mal weniger gut
aber das ist natürlich was was total auf
den Konsum drückt also wenn ich einfach
diese Unsicherheit aber auch nicht zu
wissen wann muss ich das nächste Mal
wieder zu Hause bleiben man habe ich da
wieder Verdienst Ausfälle und ähm was
ist vor allem besonders hat trifft ist
natürlich alles was was Restaurants
Tourismus was diese Branche angeht ähm
da ist einfach gerade nichts mehr zu
holen und da merken wir auch wenn wir
mit den Leuten sprechen in Totalen
Pessimismus also da ist einfach auch
keine Hoffnung keine Aussicht dass das
jetzt schnell besser wird und das drückt
natürlich total auf den den kon
sie haben vorhin gesagt wir müssten
gucken ob wir Verstärker sein können für
diese Bewegung wie könnte man das denn
machen
Verstärker meinte ich in erster Linie
das weitertragen was die Menschen zu dem
Zeitpunkt wo die Zensur zuschlägt und
die die die die
kommunikationsmauern so hoch sind dass
die Worte nicht drüber heilen wenn ich
jetzt bildlich bleiben darf dass wir das
weitertragen also wir können ja hier
frei im Deutschen Bundestag frei in der
Presse in den Nachrichten darüber
sprechen wie die Lage in der Welt ist
wie wir sie bewerten das können wir
definitiv machen und ähm darüber hinaus
erarbeitet die Bundesregierung ja gerade
eine China Strategie die lange
überfällig war die die die Union vor
allen Dingen auch die Kanzlerin in den
16 Jahren so in der Form nicht vorgelegt
hat und ich glaube deswegen auch
wertvolle Zeit verspielt hat die wir
jetzt ein Stück weit
aufarbeiten müssen und das möglichst
schnell denn auch in der Wirtschaft wird
ja darüber gesprochen wenn man mit
Verbänden spricht die nehmen gerade eine
veränderte Lage ja auch war was die
Aktivität der Kommunistischen Partei
Mitglieder in den Firmen auch in
deutschen Firmen in europäischen Firmen
in China angeht da wird es gerade
aktiver das bordmember gab es schon
immer der Kommunistischen Partei in
jeder Firma aber die verlangen mehr und
mehr Mitsprache wollen Informationen
haben und das ist etwas glaube ich was
uns zumindest
besorgen muss weil diese Entwicklung die
kommt ja nicht von ungefähr sondern das
ist genau dieser zunehmende
Interventionismus den vorhin
angesprochen habe aber klar ist auch die
Veränderungen die müssen schon aus China
selbst kommen wir können die also großes
Land wie China können wir jetzt nicht
von außen durch unsere Politik in
bestimmte Bahnen lenken ich gebe Ihnen
recht man kann das unterstützen aber
letztendlich muss der Reformwille der
muss aus der Bevölkerung selber kommen
aber wenn sie sagen der Reform will
müsst ihr trotzdem die Frage wie wir mit
unserem wichtigsten Handelspartner
umgehen sollten und es gibt ja jetzt
weil sie das gesagt dass die
china-strategie zum einen das
Auswärtigen Amtes aber heute wurden ja
auch Pläne aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium bekannt dass der
Wirtschaftsminister sagt wir müssen da
sollten weniger abhängig sein es wurde
vor einer Annexion Teil Wahnsinn Jahr
2027 gewarnt Herr GUI wie haben sie das
aufgenommen dass man jetzt sagt wir
müssen jetzt ganz klar will die
Bundesregierung weniger Abhängigkeit
entschieden
nicht ganz ehrlich bin sehe ich die Lage
an die teilweise Straße etwas anderes
ich glaube nicht dass ein akute kriegt
drohen würde es war schon seit 1949
seitdem die Volksgruppe ausgegründet
wurde da gab es der Spannung das
zwischen dem Festland und Thailand zwar
beide Beanspruchungen dass sie das eine
China ist und
die militärische Spannung gab schon
immer nur es hat eine andere qualitative
andere Qualitätsstufe reicht nachdem
China eine sogenannte
anti-haltungsgesetz also
verabschiede und dieses Gesetz hat ja
die Volksbefreiungsarmee sozusagen
legitimiert auch mit Waffengewalt jede
Vereinigung zu erreichen und da ist es
andere Quelle erreicht aber ich sehe bei
weitem noch nicht so dass das wirklich
ein Krieg droht was jetzt hier in Europa
passiert ist Russland einfach die
Ukraine 2027 das die die Idee gab's
schon immer die deswegen 2027 weil es
immer spekuliert dass sie vor Ende seine
dritten Amtszeit irgendwie eine
Wiedervereinigung erlangen möchte ja das
ist aber wirklich sehr spekulative so
offiziell als so nirgendwo öffentlich
weder über die Straße noch woanders
Grund getan also von daher kommt dieses
Jahr 2027 also ähm es ist wahrscheinlich
ist es ein Argument teilweise Argument
hier aber teilweise selbst eine
Demokratie die ja selbst sehr gut
funktioniert und läuft und die
Präsidentschaft waren steht demnächst
auch noch an also ich glaube nicht dass
das China auch wirklich mit Waffengewalt
angreift aber er hat es nicht
ausgeschlossen das ist das muss man auch
glaube ich zur Kenntnis nehmen er hat es
nicht ausgeschlafen
ich darf es aber ich tue es nicht und
dieses Gesetz hat deswegen da weil in
Taiwan die Politik so gespalten dass es
gibt die Hälfte die gerne hier tavanesen
bleiben der andere möchte Ihnen gerne
möglicherweise mich hier ein bisschen
mit dem Fesseln hier ein bisschen näher
kommen aber das Gesetz der immer so
Abschreckung jedes Mal wenn die Wahlen
anstehen dann wird immer aus dem ärmer
gezaubert eine weder Raketen Drohnen
oder was aber das ist in den letzten
Jahrzehnte das gar nicht geben aber
Tatsache ist natürlich dass wir
wirtschaftlich extrem abhängig sind dass
sie ganze halt leider Produktion all das
brauchen wir aus Taiwan im großen Umfang
und auch andere Dinge die aus China kurz
wie bewerten sie das dass die
Bundesregierung gesagt wir müssen klarer
wenige abhängig sein das hat natürlich
auch mit den Entwicklungen in Russland
zu tun dass man denselben Fehler nichts
machen möchte also weniger abhängig sein
sollte jetzt nicht bedeuten sich völlig
aus dem China Geschäft zurückzuziehen
zum einen hier ist auch der Vergleich
nicht so gut gelungen wenn man sagt
China versus Deutschland wenn dann
müsste man China im
außenwirtschaftsverkehr ja mit der
Europäischen Union vergleichen und das
spielen beide in einer ähnlichen Liga
und da sind auch beide voneinander in
ähnlichem Umfang abhängig also ist nicht
nur so dass wir von China abhängig sind
Chinas auch von der Europäischen Union
abhängig darin ist Deutschland dann der
größte Teilraum aber letztendlich
sind wir eben nicht auf gedei und
verderbt hier den Chinesen ausgeliefert
klar die wir müssen jetzt auch sehen
für seine schiere große kantina Nichts
sind 1,4 Milliarden Menschen die sich
jetzt in den vergangenen Jahren auch
ökonomisch wachsend entwickelt haben und
die wollen natürlich auch zu mehr
Wohlstand weiterhin kommen das ist ja
auch vollkommen berechtigt so wie das
alle anderen Länder eben auch wollen und
für diese Tiere Größe selber kann China
nicht das heißt dass wir etwas zehn
Prozent unseres Außenhandels mit der
jetzt mit dem zweitgrößten
Wirtschaftsraum der Welt
betreiben das ist jetzt jetzt auch nicht
irgendwie besonders auffällig man würde
sich eher wundern wenn wir dort sehr
wenig Handel betreiben würden nehmen Sie
mal die vier wiesegrad-staaten mit denen
haben wir noch viel intensivere
Handelsbeziehungen das heißt nur weil
China groß ist muss noch lange keine
Bedrohung sein okay
wie wird denn der EU-Ratspräsident
michelle war jetzt ja gerade in China
die Frage wie schaut man von China aus
nach in die EU Frau Steimer
und versucht man da noch mehr sozusagen
den Handel zu intensivieren oder gibt es
da auch Punkte wo man ja vielleicht eine
andere Haltung bekommt
china hatte immer eine sehr pragmatische
Herangehensweise zu sagen es gibt da
natürlich Themen wo wir uns nicht einig
sind aber lasst uns doch das auf der
handelsebene sofort führen wie wir wie
wir da die guten Erfahrungen gemacht
haben interessant ist gerade in die die
Diskussion um um die neue China
Strategie Deutschlands dass das ähm hier
durchaus sehr beachtet wird also es gibt
ja immer wieder Fragen zu das hören wir
auch aus aus verschiedenen Ecken dass
das immer wieder nachgefragt wird und
was kommt denn jetzt und was hat man
dazu erwarten und auch als jetzt diese
ersten Entwürfe
veröffentlicht wurden hat das hier
tatsächlich ein wieder heil gehabt auch
in den Medien also das weißt was ähm was
was was ja was eine große Beachtung
findet weil das natürlich im
ausschlaggebend ist wie die
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen sich
weiterentwickeln werden befürchtet man
da dass das sich die oder dass ich dann
konkret auch Deutschland mehr
zurückzieht
ja das ist ganz klar eine Befürchtung
also gerade auch wenn wir jetzt auf den
den Besuch von Olaf Scholz schauen da
waren China natürlich sehr zufrieden wie
das gelaufen ist dass er da war als der
der erste große westliche auch seit
Beginn der Pandemie kurz nach dem
Parteitag das dieser Besuch gelaufen ist
nach Chinas Spielregeln mit den ganzen
Corona Restriktionen die das Land den
Besuch auferlegt hat und die ihn ja auch
durchaus schwierig gemacht haben dass
auch nicht so außer irgendwie ein
normalerweise aussieht ähm das Olaf
Scholz mit einer Wirtschaftsdelegation
zusammen kann das ist natürlich auch die
Hoffnung dass die guten
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen wie sie unter
Merkel viele Jahre stattgefunden haben
so weitergeführt werden können
Sie denn sagen man braucht Daten ja ein
härteren Bruch und man sollte versuchen
klar die Abhängigkeit zu reduzieren oder
ist das wir haben das ja bei der
Diskussion und den Hamburger und das
Hamburger Container Terminal mitbekommen
jeder Dr Containern der nach Hamburg
geht kommt aus China also würden Sie
sagen da müssen wir eigentlich wirklich
grundsätzlich Umsteuern also was die
china-strategie um einmal in diesem Bild
zu bleiben versucht zu leisten ist nicht
das ganze Problem zu lösen das schaffen
wir mit nicht mit 70 Seiten auch nicht
mit 100 Seiten ich glaube der erste
Schritt ist festzuhalten die
china-strategie der Bundesregierung ist
eigentlich ressortübergreifend angelegt
die wird zwar maßgeblich im Auswärtigen
Amt geschrieben aber die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen dort haben auch andere Fach
Ressorts selbstverständlich mit
eingebunden sonst würde es keine
china-strategie sein sondern ein ein
politischer diplomatischer Teil im
Umgang mit erfolgsrepublik deswegen
würde ich auch vorschlagen dass das bmwk
und das Auswärtige Amt vielleicht noch
mal korrespondieren aus meiner Sicht
nicht sinnvoll ist jetzt ein weiteres
Papier
von Kabinett Ebene oder von wird von
Ministeriums Ebene zu machen das das
Bildungsministerium war daran beteiligt
auch Länder Kolleginnen und Kollegen
waren beteiligt aber wir wollen ja einen
stringenten weg was ist Ziel zu sagen
wir wollen unabhängiger sein wir wollen
nicht mit den Fehler machen den wir in
dem Energiesektor mit Russland gemacht
haben ist Ziel wir wollen nicht
Handeltreiben mit einem Land dass seine
Bevölkerung gängelt also was ist Ziel
das Ziel ist und ich da würde ich so ein
bisschen anknüpfen das was vorher sagten
ähm nicht aus China rauszugehen das ist
absolut unrealistisch und ich glaube da
muss man tatsächlich pragmatisch sein
aber das was wir beeinflussen können ist
ja die zu diversifizieren wir haben
heute gerade im Bundestag ceta
ratifiziert wir können ja unsere Kinder
das Handelsabkommen mit Kanada weitere
sollen folgen wir wollen auch ttip 2.0
vielleicht suchen wir uns einen anderen
Namen wir wollen mit Mexiko mit
Brasilien ähm
Freihandel ich glaube das war ja das was
der Kanzler auch sagte mit nordpointing
every egg in Pudding er sind differen
Baskets oder ich kann es gerade nicht so
schön formulieren wie er das hat also
genau man stellt sich breit auf und ich
glaube das sollten wir auch mit Blick
auf China machen und dennoch muss man
sagen wenn die EU der Sparingspartner
zur Volksrepublik ist dann müssen wir
trotzdem dafür sorgen auch auf EU-Ebene
dass die das level playing field einen
einen ebenbürtiges ist und das hat ja
mit dem mit dem Investitionsabkommen was
ja die Kanzlerin noch kurz vor Ende der
deutschen Ratspräsidentschaft versuchte
das zeigt nicht geschafft weil das für
europäische oder auch für deutsche
Firmen einen Nachteil in China gegeben
hätte und deswegen war das eigentlich
ein Fehler also dieses Level level
playing fiel diversifizieren und mehr
mit Demokratien in der Welt einfach
freien Handel treiben weil das ist am
Ende das was unsere Stärke dann ausmacht
und dann können wir auch mehr Regeln
bestimmen zu den äh zu denen wir mit
Menschenrechten und
internationaler Ordnung kommen wollen
das ist der Weg ist das ein guter Weg
oder wird das könnte das funktionieren
dass man
überwirtschaftlichen Druck letztendlich
dann auch die Innenpolitik in China
verändert oder ist das naiv
ich glaube sie kann sich nur verändern
wenn das Land selbst will glaube man
kann draußen nicht wirklich viel machen
was wir machen könnten ist was
vorhersing gesagt hat wir sind
Verstärker für diese Stimme die in China
selbst nicht gehört werden und die
müssen wir die verstärken und an die
internationale Gemeinschaft weitergeben
was der Hand der betrifft wie wir das
Ziel erreichen
ich bin auch genau ein wirtschaftlichen
die ein Pragmatik ich bin der Meinung
dass wir gerne kritisch und immer wieder
auf die Menschenrechtslage in China
schauen und dabei müssen wir immer das
klare Ziel vor Augen haben wir reden
über die Menschenrechten China nicht nur
einfach zu sagen schon mal her falsch
machen anders sondern wir müssen nicht
nur über China reden sondern mit China
reden
asiatischen Kulturkreis Denkmal sehr an
schwarz oder weiße denkt man z.B ihn und
Yang entweder du bist mein Freund du
bist mein Freund rede ich immer wenn du
Zeit gibt es keine Austausch schlimmer
wäre wenn China die Türen zumacht und
sagt wir reden nicht mehr mit
Deutschland über die Menschen
Deutschland hat sie in der vergangenen
Jahren immer sehr gute Erfolge erzielt
zum Beispiel dass man Mechanismus
etabliert hat nennt sich der Mensch
recht Dialog mit China und da hat man
inzwischen die Themen sind nicht mehr
immer aus meiner Überzeugung nicht immer
treffend aber wir haben diesen
Mechanismus der könnte man nutzen und
das hat nicht jeder und was hat man mit
Russland auch so man dieses Wandel durch
Handel und das hat eben auch gar nicht
funktioniert oder würden kann man das
nicht vergleichen ja Wandel und Handel
es kommt darauf an was man verändern
möchte Hannah geht immer
Handel ist immer der Türöffner Stellen
vor 40 Jahren in China ging um einfach
Joint Venture zu gründen und da hätten
die deutschen Autobahn heute nicht so
eine riesen Erfolg und musste Mut haben
zu sagen wir gehen dahin eine Markt wo
die Menschenrechtslage nicht so sein wie
wir uns wünschen aber wir sind immer da
um zu zeigen wie wir es machen dass
seine Volkswagen Vorbild einfach einen
anderen deutschen Investoren haben nicht
nur den Arbeitsschutz mitgebracht die
haben ja hier die die Gehälter mit dem
angepasst und das ganze soziale Belange
haben wir vorbildlich gemacht damit man
weiß wie es Deutschland funktioniert und
da sind die ersten Botschafter jenseits
von der Politik und das weiß man auch in
China gibt so viele Klischee über
deutsche Investoren dass die Deutschland
so ein tolles Land ist Deutschland hat
die China ein sehr sehr gutes Image wenn
man normale Menschen spricht man mit
Deutschen spricht dann zeigt nur einen
Daumen alles gut
wie viel Druck kann man ausüben wenn das
so positiv ist das Image ist das ein
Punkt wo sie sagen ja da muss die
Wirtschaft auch ja mehr Verantwortung
übernehmen dass sie auf diese
Menschenrechtsverletzung auf all das
aufmerksam macht dass sie der Druck
aussieht oder sagen Sie das ist einfach
überhaupt nicht Aufgabe wird Druck kann
man da relativ wenig erreichen zumal bei
einem so großen Land aber man kann eben
miteinander in den Austausch kommen
stellen sich mal vor da ist jemand auf
Parteilinie dem wurde die ganze Zeit
gesagt nur weil wir hier ein autoritäres
Regime haben haben wir die Harmonie
haben wir überhaupt ein funktionsfähiges
Gemeinwesen dann kommt dieser Mensch
wegen Handelsbeziehungen mal hier nach
Westeuropa und stellt fest oh eine
liberale Demokratie die Menschen können
sich frei äußern und über alles
Wohlstand das ist doch ein viel
nachdrücklicheres Argument für das was
wir uns für eine
freiheitliche Gesellschaft vorstellen
als immer den erhobenen Zeigefinger nach
Peking zu tragen und deshalb klar Wandel
durch Handel das ist kein Automatismus
aber ein sehr begünstigender Faktor und
den würde ich auch nicht unterschätzen
der braucht eben Zeit ja gegen die Wand
gefahren
da war es nicht erfolgreich wir wissen
ja nicht wie es gekommen wäre wenn wir
uns vor 20 Jahren völlig aus Russland
zurückgezogen hätten und wir jetzt
lauter Nordkoreas auf der Welt entstehen
lassen das wäre jetzt mein Gegenbeispiel
also Nordkorea haben wir praktisch alle
Brücken abgebrochen wir sehen aber nicht
dass das Land sich deshalb irgendwie
schneller dem Westen oder unseren Werten
noch einmal es ist keine Garantie aber
es ist ein Weg wie wir mit unseren Ideen
dort vordringen und die Demonstration
ich würde jetzt nicht überbewerten aber
die sind eben auch ein Ruf nach Freiheit
und das kommt eben auch daher dass die
Menschen wissen es gibt dort an anderen
Teilen der Welt andere gesellschaftliche
Systeme die mehr Freiheit mit mehr
Wohlstand vereinbaren können dass sie
dann sich gegen die Strategie von habe
ich aussprechen würden dass die
deutschen Firmen weniger abhängig sein
sollten also die Abhängigkeit also ist
ich habe ja gesagt die sollen sich nicht
zurückziehen man muss hier die
Unternehmen aber auch nicht zum Jagen
tragen deshalb bin ich so ein bisschen
kritisch denn wenn sie auf die jüngsten
Unternehmensbefragungen schauen dann
haben die allermeisten Unternehmen die
in China Geschäft unterwegs sind ja
selber verstanden
gerade jetzt auch nach der Erfahrung in
Russland dass man sich etwas
diversifizierte aufstellen muss also
China plus eins ist da dann
also immer noch einen weiteren
Lieferanten zu haben das ist im Zweifel
auch wichtiger als bei den Absatzmärkten
da mache ich mir ohnehin weniger Sorgen
aber das wissen die Unternehmen auch
selber die muss man jetzt nicht noch
durch staatliche Vorschriften
dazu sehr einschränken und was die
Investitionstätigkeit angeht Chinas hier
in Deutschland ich glaube das wird
vollkommen überschätzt also der Anteil
chinesischer Direktinvestitionen an den
gesamten deutschen Direktinvestitionen
die in unser Land kommen der ist so
gering Costco ist ja gerade formuliert
worden oder genannt worden
aber jede weltweit aktive Reederei hat
typischerweise auch Beteiligungen an
Standort das macht auch
betriebswirtschaftlich sind wir müssen
den Chinesen dann schon zugestehen dass
das was andere für ihre Geschäftsmodelle
für sinnvoll erhalten dass sie das eben
auch machen und wir wittern dann immer
eine ja eine üble Strategie dahinter da
sollten wir uns auch vielleicht nicht zu
sehr
ja davon leiten lassen dass das so ein
Reich des Übels wäre was uns immer nur
in Abhängigkeiten zwingend ich würde
ganz gerne einmal noch dazu holen und
dann sie natürlich sonst weil sie hat
den Nachteil dass sie zugeschaltet ist
Frau Steimer wenn wir das jetzt so hören
wie mit welcher Erwartung oder was
erwarten denn zum Beispiel die Menschen
der Protestbewegung haben gibt es da was
wo sie sagen da könnten auch durch
wirtschaftliche Nähe oder
wirtschaftliche Verbundenheit könnte man
uns helfen
unsere Ziele zu erreichen
ich wurde gerade noch ergänzen ich finde
diesen Blick in die in die in die andere
Welt ganz spannend weil ich glaube das
ein
ein vielleicht mit Auslöser für den
Zeitpunkt der Proteste vielleicht auch
die Fußball Weltmeisterschaft sein kann
also das ist wirklich für viele Chinesin
und Chinesen auch ein Blick in in das
Leben das mit dem Coronavirus in anderen
Ländern einfach ganz anders aussieht
also der Blick in volle Stadien in in
die Ränge wo die Menschen ohne Masken
sitzen ähm es gab im chinesischen Staats
wenn sogar
Vergleiche wie wie das Signal aussieht
also dass sowas auch ausgeschnitten wird
am Anfang gab es auf auf dem tiktok
Pendant auch erste Videos wo so sagen
die Ränge geblatt waren um das nicht so
deutlich zu machen ich glaube das ist
für viele wirklich auch der Blick ist in
in so sieht das in anderen Ländern aus
die inzwischen eine andere Strategie
fahren mit diesem Virus zu leben und das
ist schon auch wirklich in
entscheidender Blick und mit dem anderen
Aspekt zu dem zu dem positiven Image das
würde ich total unterstützen also wir
merken das auch wenn wir als als
Drehteam unterwegs sind
als ausländisches
Journalistenteam hat man eigentlich
schlechte Karten in China weil natürlich
die die straßenpropaganda den Menschen
erzählt die verbreiten nur Lügen sprecht
auf keinen Fall mit denen das ist
natürlich nicht überall so wir werden
ganz oft sehr freundlich empfangen aber
wirklich ist Deutschland ganz ganz
häufig ein Türöffner also ist immer die
Frage wo kommt ihr her wenn man dann
noch irgendwie zumindest mal drei Wörter
Chinesisch sprechen kann wird man auch
sofort sehr sehr nett aufgenommen und
dann ist das erste was wir hören wenn
wir sagen wir sind aus Deutschland
meistens irgendein bekannter Fußballer
Name z.B und Merkel also merkt das auch
wirklich ein Name der dann ganz häufig
fällt und das ist wirklich dieses
positive Image dass ich total bestätigen
würde dass wir als als Deutsche in China
absolut so erfahren aber gibt's eine
konkrete Erwartung in Deutschland dann
die wir haben einen schönen Trick
gemacht kurz vor dem Besuch von Olaf
Scholz wo wir genau danach gefragt haben
und ich erinnere mich an einen in so
einem typisch deutschen Brauhaus und
haben mit einem Chinesen gesprochen der
dann sagte ja äh Merkel und super und
wieso müssen wir uns denn streiten es
läuft doch super mit der Wirtschaft lass
uns das doch einfach so weitermachen ist
jetzt so eine eine sehr typische aber
bisschen klischeehafte aber eine Stimme
die wir ganz häufig so hören klar
ist ziemlich offen Freundeskreis das
lassen wir weitermachen mit der Handel
Beziehung ich persönlich hätte ein
bisschen Probleme mit dem Wort
Abhängigkeit ich glaube Deutschland ist
nicht wirklich von China abhängig die
ganze Welt ist von China bringe ich
diese Abhängigkeit und diese intende
Tendenz würde ich nicht Abhängigkeit
bezeichnen sondern das ist die
natürliche Folge der Globalisierung wir
sagen wir sind alle für die
Globalisierung wir sind für eine
international organisierte Lieferketten
die müssen damit leben das einzelne
Länder in diese Kette sind die wir nicht
so gerne mögen die andere Systeme haben
eine andere politische Ordnung haben die
anders als wir sind aber die sind
automatisch Teil der Lieferkette der
Groteske dabei dran ist dass diese
Lieferkette eigentlich das Ergebnis der
unternehmerische Aktivitäten sind ohne
dass die Regierung aktiv das zu Längen
weil die die Unternehmen suchen
billigsten Anbieter auf dem
internationalen Markt und sorgt dafür
dass sie waren pünktlich geliefert
werden und dass das ist die Folge der
Globalisierung würde sagen man ein
bisschen
großzügiger ist in dem Sinne auch von
Deutschland abhängig stellen sich mal
vor 14 Millionen Arbeitsplätze ist die
statistisch gelesen habe sind von
Deutschland von der Europäischen Union
abhängig also das ist wer ist von wem
mehr abhängig sprechen dass Deutschland
und die EU mehr Einfluss nehmen könnten
Aspekt Wandel durch Handel ist
gescheitert ich glaube man kann es ja
genauso gut andersrum drehen auch China
versucht ja Wandel durch Handeln auf
nach ihrer Lesart zu machen wir machen
ja nichts anderes in der Welt es gibt
zwei Wirtschaftskreisläufe ein intern
einen externen und ich möchte Ihnen in
einem Punkt widersprechen dass ich schon
wahrnehmen und auch in Gesprächen immer
wieder feststelle das bestätigt wird
dass alles was aus von von China gerade
ausgeht sei es jetzt wirtschaftlich als
auch gesellschaftlich schon einen
langfristigen Plan zu haben scheint es
sind schon mehrere also Mosaiksteine die
das Bild vervollständigen und deswegen
möchte ich auch sagen dass das cosco
eine Debatte war die sich sicherlich ein
Stück weit Bahn gebrochen hat weil man
gerade auch in dieses aus Fehlern lernen
Argument anwenden konnte mit Blick auf
Russland dass man es überhaupt nicht
vergleichen kann das ist glaube ich doch
im zweiten oder tieferen Blick sehr klar
aber dennoch ist eine hafenbeteiligung
an einem strategischen Knotenpunkt der
Hafeninfrastruktur in Europa
beispielsweise auch eines dieser
Mosaiksteinchen und wir werden ja wohl
hoffentlich nicht denken dass China sich
jetzt mit den zwei 24, 90 Prozent
zufrieden geben wird es wird ja weitere
Verhandlungen in den nächsten Jahren
geben das ist ja nicht der Punkt ich
möchte nur damit sagen dass die dass das
etwas ist wo wir mein Kollege nennt es
immer China Stresstest dass wir genau
und das glaube ich passiert auch in den
Unternehmen die sind ja die sind ja
nicht nur weltgewandt sondern auch
planen ja in die Zukunft und das müssen
wir politisch machen wie wir das auch
von Unternehmen erwarten ein Blick in
die Zukunft machen und bewerten wo
unsere resilienzen größer werden müssen
und das versucht auch die
china-strategie ein Stück ich glaube wir
müssen das dann aber auch mit Leben
füllen und es nicht nur auf dem Papier
stehen
um die Beteiligung an einem Terminal und
das eigentliche Investitionsrisiko liegt
auf chinesischer Seite denn wenn es
wirklich zu einem Konflikt käme zwischen
Deutschland und der Europäischen Union
auf der einen Seite und China auf der
anderen Seite dann würde man im Zweifel
sehr schnell hier zu einer Enteignung
schreiten oder sonstige Regulierung
einführen das den Weiterbetrieb dieses
Terminals eben ermöglicht wenn das im
deutschen Interesse ist also da würde
ich jetzt auch die Gefahr nicht so groß
an die Wand malen und was die
Stresstests angeht die Unternehmen
selber sollen das tun werden sie auch
tun auch die Kapitalmärkte schauen sehr
genau da drauf
sind einzelne Unternehmen sehr stark
exponiert gegenüber einzelnen Ländern
zumal dann wenn sie politisch
problematisch sind und werden das
entsprechend ab da ist es dann aber
wichtig dass die Politik auch klar macht
wir werden euch auch nicht raushauen
wenn es
schief läuft wenn dann wird genau diese
Disziplinierung über die Kapitalmärkte
eben nicht erfolgen also wir haben ja
auch eine eigene ordnungspolitische
Aufgabe sicherzustellen dass die
Unternehmen genau schauen welche Risiken
gehen sie ein und ein staatlicher
Stresstest für die Abhängigkeit von die
verketten davor würde ich warnen denn
wenn wir das dann tun da kommen
irgendwelche Ergebnisse raus und da wo
es dann am Ende wirklich mal
problematisch wird wird man
wahrscheinlich nicht entdecken über
einen solchen stress test dann gibt es
ein Problem und Unternehmen werden sagen
wir haben alles gemacht was wir was wir
von uns wolltet ihr staatliche Aufseher
jetzt ist es schief gegangen jetzt müsst
ihr uns auch wieder aus der Patsche
helfen und das sollten wir nicht wir
sollen nicht so ein Modus kommen dass am
Ende das Risiko immer wieder beim Start
abgeladen wird ich glaube die
ordnungspolitischen Instrumente hat der
Stader alle Freihandel ich glaube die
Bundesregierung hat ja die
außenwirtschaftsordnung angepasst und
hat mir jüngsten Zeit ein paar
übernahmen zum Chips Hersteller in
Deutschland durch chinesischen
Investoren und bei dem einen Fall durch
den Tochtergesellschaften Schweden und
sagt und das signavit in China falsch
das ist falsch also wird alles
interpretiert und zu sagen Deutschland
Nationen wir brauchen die Globalisierung
und warum baut Deutschland künstliche
Hürden bei solche internationale
Kooperation weil es ist sehr das sind
das sind das sind die Fragen die die
gestellt wurden und die die kann man so
nicht einfach politisch übrigens auch
Eigentum Eingriffe in die
Eigentumsrechte der deutschen Verkäufer
das darf man dabei auch nicht übersehen
also sie dürfen dann nicht mehr an den
Meistbietenden in der Welt verkaufen das
ist ja durchaus ein Eingriff in ihr
eigenes Eigentumsrecht
wird gern noch einmal auch Barrieren
für in China investieren ja aber
von einem verabschieden wir können nicht
glauben dass wir alles was andere Länder
in der Wirtschaftspolitik anders machen
als wir und was wir aus guten Gründen
auch für nicht marktwirtschaftlich
halten in irgendeiner Weise denn
replizieren und sagen das versuchen wir
zu kompensieren indem wir hier eigene
Interventionen in Deutschland fahren
erstens wird das in China die Politik
gar nicht ändern und was ich viel
problematischer finde wir werden dann im
Laufe der Zeit selber immer chinesischer
weil wir jede Intervention in China
irgendwie replizieren also eine
Subvention für irgendein
Wirtschaftsbereich in China versuchen
wir dann zu kompensieren um ein level
playing field herzustellen indem wir
selber subventionieren lasst uns nicht
auf diesen Wettlauf sich einlassen
sondern im Zweifel dann die Chinesen ja
die Lektion selber lernen indem sie
merken dass das auf Dauer auch keine
gute Strategie ist ich würde gerne noch
einen anderen Punkt in den letzten fünf
Minuten besprechen nämlich die Frage
wenn wir auf die Weltpolitik schauen
dann schauen wir natürlich jetzt auch
gerade auf unseren Umgang mit in
Russland mit diesem Angriffskrieg in der
Ukraine welche Rolle kann China da
spielen das war ja auch ein Thema des
Besuches des Bundeskanzlers Frau Steimer
spielt der Krieg überhaupt eine Rolle
wird darüber viel berichtet und wie wird
die Rolle Chinas da gesehen um Einfluss
vielleicht auf Russland ausüben zu
können
ja also China versucht er ja weiter den
Spagat den dass er Anfang an hat also
kurz vor Kriegsausbruch haben sich Putin
und hier noch mal ihrer grenzenlosen
Freundschaft versichert
ich glaube dass ich die die die Position
nicht sehr geändert hat also es ist
immer noch dieser Versuch auf der einen
Seite
durchaus auch wirtschaftlich in Lücken
vorzustoßen die der besten jetzt
hinterlässt durch die Sanktionen auf der
anderen Seite aber auch nicht so eine
Rückendeckung zu geben dass man sich mit
westlicher Seite vor allem mit diesem
wichtigen Wirtschaftspartner für dieses
Land versaut also das ist die Position
von China und die die hält das Land ja
auch weiter durch und versucht auf
beiden Seiten das mitzunehmen was ich da
mitnehmen lässt die Steige ist wenn die
Ölimporte sind gestiegen also der gibt's
ja ganz klar eine Verbindung zwischen
China und Russland Frau Jensen was haben
sie da Hoffnung das ist da eine
Möglichkeit gibt Einfluss auf Russland
auszuüben dass wir das durch unsere Art
mit China umzugehen beeinflussen können
ich habe immer den Eindruck dass
der Ordnungszwang nenne ich das jetzt
mal der der Kommunistischen Partei nicht
zu dem Vorgehen von Putin passt und dass
wir deswegen da auch eine keine gute
Resonanz haben ich glaube an Stellen wo
sie zusammenarbeiten müssen oder von von
chinesischer Seite Wertung wird das
wahrscheinlich auch weiterhin passieren
aber man hat ja zum Beispiel bei beim
doch ja fahrlässigen Umgang mit mit dem
Atomkraftwerk in saporizia gesehen das
auch auch ich glaube ich selbst das auch
sehr kritisch gesehen hat dass man schon
merkte okay da ist ein irgendeine Art
von Verantwortungsbewusstsein der Welt
gegenüber dass da vielleicht noch in ihm
Ruth und deswegen würde ich die beiden
nicht unbedingt auf dieser Ebene
Augenhöhe sehen ich glaube das ist so
das ist so ein bisschen wie
Lukaschenko und Putin das passt auch
nicht so wirklich das ist manchmal von
Putin schon so glaube ich ist es
manchmal von schießgnaden
weil das doch unterschiedliche Systeme
ja sind aber man merkt schon dass
Russland isolierter ist und China in der
Abwägung glaube ich auch eher in der
Kosten nutzenrechnung glaubt dass es
vernetzter bleiben muss um auch ein
Stück weit seine eigenen Ziele weiterhin
in der Welt erreichen zu können deswegen
ich bin da unentschlossen aber das wäre
meine meine
Subsumierung stand jetzt ich bin
gespannt
ich glaube es ist die größte Erfolg als
der Bundeskanzler scheut sich China war
das sehr sich mit Staatspräsident darauf
geeinigt hat alles darauf hinzuarbeiten
das Russland keine Atomwaffen einsetzt
ich glaube das ist schon mein großer
Schritt und das liegt auch nicht im
Interesse China dass das Russland aus
irgendeinem Grund wie groß es sein auch
sein mag Atombombe Apfel das doch viel
arbeiten ich glaube schon sehr sehr
kleine kleine Geste aber große
Auswirkungen großes Signal
Russland Putin dass der Krieg sobald so
schnell wie möglich zu Ende geführt wird
und das kann Atombombe eingesetzt wird
also das wäre eine Möglichkeit dass man
da das ist schon mal ein guter Schritt
irgendwie genauso wie sie diesen Besuch
des Bundeskanzler auch als positiv sehen
genau
schauen wir noch mal auf die
Protestbewegung auf die haben wir am
Anfang geschaut wir viele denken ja dann
dann noch mal an den vierten juni 1989
Frau Steimer ist sowas denkt man spielt
das mit eine Rolle die blutige
Niederschlagung damals sehr Proteste und
das ähm am Platz des Himmlischen
Friedens wird das ist ja immer noch
etwas worüber nicht gesprochen wird wenn
ich richtig informiert wenn also gibt's
da irgendwie Parallelen
natürlich haben das viele im Kopf und
viele sagen die Proteste in diesem
Ausmaß das ist das erste Mal seit 89
dass wir das so erleben es gibt glaube
ich ein paar Unterschiede das ist
natürlich im wie sich die Welt seither
weiterentwickelt hat auch welche
welche
digitalen Fortschritte ist seither gibt
also wie weiterentwickelt die das
digitale Überwachungssystem hier ist was
natürlich ein ganz großer Unterschied
ist und auch in der in der Ausbildung
der Sicherheitskräfte was was noch mal
was ganz anderes ist es sind eben auch
sowas vorbereitet das sieht man ja auch
aktuell also ich glaube ganz akut sind
diese sind diese Proteste jetzt für Sie
oder für die Kommunistische Partei
werden ihm zuerst mal nicht extrem
gefährlich aber natürlich ist es was was
brodelt und so ein Funke der schnell
überspringen kann deshalb reagiert die
Staatsführung ja auch so wie sie gerade
reagiert weil sie merkt dass das Brot
und wir müssen das ein eng bevor das
mehr wird ich glaube das Besondere ist
tatsächlich dass der davon aus dass er
dieser Proteste also es gibt ja in China
immer wieder Proteste aus den
verschiedenen Gründen aber normalerweise
trifft es irgendeine Gruppe und in
diesem Fall ist wirklich das Besondere
daran dass diese strikten
corona-maßnahmen einfach die ganze
Bevölkerung betreffen also da alle sich
angeht genau eine kleine Gruppe sondern
das ist für alle gleich ja vielen Dank
Frau Steimer für die Schilderungen aus
vaging und alles Gute Ihnen dort ich
weiß dass sie noch was sagen wollte aber
wir sind am Ende der Sendung aber wir
werden bestimmt noch öfter über dieses
Thema reden vielen Dank Herr kussi und
ihnen vielen Dank fürs zuschauen jetzt
geht's ja weiter mit Phoenix der Tag bis
dann tschüss
[Musik]
[Gelächter]